MURAT: [Musik]
Dam-da-dam-daaa! Dam-da-dam-daaa!
Oh, die Wurst! Sally!
Wasser! Sally!
SALLY: Murat!
MURAT: Feuer! Sally!
Murats 5 Minuten!
Murat, ernschthaft?!
DIDI: Ein großer Menschheitstraum
oder ein großer Traum von mir geht in Erfüllung.
Ich darf endlich mit Murat ein Video drehen.
[Jubel] Genau, mit Murat zusammen. [Didi stimmt zu]
MURAT: Und für meine Zuschauer…
Der Didi ist sozusagen der österreichische Murat.
Ein Haubenkoch - er hat richtig was drauf.
Wir kennen uns seit inzwischen 5 Jahren.
DIDI: Weil aus der Volksschule haben sie uns ja beide auseinandergesetzt.
MURAT: Genau.
DIDI: Darum wurde unsere Beziehung leider unterbrochen,
aber jetzt sind wir wieder zusammen.
Heute machen wir etwas ganz Schwieriges und zwar…
Für Murat schwierig, für mich eher leicht.
MURAT: Ja.
DIDI: Es ist eine österreichische Delikatesse,
und zwar Palatschinken.
MURAT: Also Palatschinken - das ist auf Deutsch gesagt:
Das machen die Österreicher immer gerne.
Die verwenden einen anderen Begriff.
Für uns ist es ein Pfannkuchen, für ihn ist es ein Palatschinken.
DIDI: Oder für Franzosen Crêpe. [Murat stimmt zu].
Das ist dann Gourmet.
MURAT: Die übertreiben es wieder; die Franzosen übertreiben.
DIDI: Herrlich. Die werden so hübsch wie wir Zwei.
MURAT: Oh, danke! [Beide lachen]
DIDI: Oh, er entblößt sogar die Haare.
MURAT: So, auf jeden Fall… Was ich jetzt sagen wollte.
DIDI: Jetzt willst du wissen, wie es geht, oder?
MURAT: Einen Pfannkuchen kriegt ein Murat noch hin!
DIDI: Okay, dann würde ich sagen, es geht jetzt los.
Und als Jury haben wir die einzigartige Sally.
Sie wird dann sagen, ob es gut schmeckt oder nicht.
MURAT: Aber sie darf dann nicht sehen, wer es gemacht hat, okay?
DIDI: Nein, da machen wir eine Blindverkostung.
MURAT: Alles klar.
DIDI: Wir sind so kreativ. Unglaublich!
MURAT: Ist es jetzt ein Freundschaftsspiel zwischen Deutschland und…
BEIDE: Österreich.
MURAT: Ja, genau.
DIDI: Da wir ja im Fußball mittlerweile sehr gut sind.
Und auch im Skifahren - das erwähnen wir immer so nebenbei ganz gerne.
MURAT: Skifahren? [Didi bejaht]
DIDI: Welche Sportart kannst du eigentlich?
MURAT: Ringen und Tontaubenschießen.
DIDI: Ringen? Ja, du bist wirklich ein kleiner Ringer.
MURAT: Also.
DIDI: Gut. Ich würde sagen, du gibst mal das Mehl hinein, oder?
MURAT: Genau. Palatschinken gegen Pfannkuchen.
DIDI: Genau. Zack, zack, zack.
MURAT: Alles klar.
DIDI: Du tust gleich mal alles, gell?
MURAT: Nicht bei mir abschauen!
DIDI: Nein, du darfst auch nicht bei mir gucken.
Ich tu jetzt die Eier rein.
Aber mein Trick ist,
damit die Palatschinken oder eben die Crêpe richtig schön…
Ja, Sally. Schau, deine Frau guckt schon zu.
MURAT: Ich mache zuerst die Milch rein, weil das sorgt dafür,
dass der Teig etwas fluffiger wird.
DIDI: Und ich tu aber vorher jetzt schon alles miteinander verrühren,
damit ich dann keine Klumpen habe.
Und jetzt schön langsam die Milch dazu.
MURAT: Glaubt ihm nicht! Er lügt. [Didi verneint]
SALLY: Kriege ich später Pfannkuchen von euch?
DIDI: Leckerschmecker!
So, Herr Kollege, jetzt brauchen wir aber noch Schöpfer, gell?
MURAT: Ja.
DIDI: Kennst du dich hier aus?
Oh, Sally du hast ein Mikro dabei. Das ist gut!
SALLY: Darf ich später die Jury sein?
DIDI: Ja, unbedingt. Du musst die Jury sein.
SALLY: Und ich beurteile aber nur das Ergebnis, ja?
MURAT: Ja, so ist es.
SALLY: Nicht den…
DIDI: Nicht den…
SALLY: Nicht den Rechenweg.
MURAT: Nicht wer hübscher ist, weil dann hätte ich schon gewonnen.
DIDI: Dann hätte ich wieder verloren.
Bitte schaut! Schaut das nicht herrlich aus?
MURAT: Ja…
DIDI: Unglaublich!
MURAT: Abwarten!
MURAT: Weil es nachher zählt, was rauskommt.
DIDI: Für die Sally zählt aber nicht nur, wie es ausschaut,
sondern auch der Geschmack.
Darum wichtig, bitte: Vanille!
MURAT: Machst du gerade eine Produktplatzierung?
Wir müssen es dann aber kennzeichnen.
Aber eins muss ich zugeben.
Deiner sieht irgendwie ein bisschen klumpfreier aus.
DIDI: Ja, ein bisschen, aber deiner…
Ja, da kannst du eine ganze Fußballmannschaft damit bekochen.
MURAT: Das Besondere an meinem Pfannkuchen:
Ich habe ein bisschen Klumpen drin,
aber diese Klumpen sorgen für diesen besonderen Geschmack,
weil sie nachher Lufteinschlüsse im Pfannkuchen sind.
DIDI: Genau, oder wenn es dann auf der Zunge ist, dann denkt man sich:
Worauf habe ich denn da wieder gebissen? [Beide lachen]
Das sind die Momente.
MURAT: So, gut.
DIDI: Starten wir!
Deiner schaut aber schon sehr gut aus.
MURAT: Dankeschön.
DIDI: So schaut's bei mir aus
und so sauber ist es bei dir.
Ich weiß jetzt, warum die Sally dich geheiratet hat.
Ja, das ist schon so, gell?
MURAT: Ja, aber es liegt auch daran…
DIDI: Der sauberste Mann der Welt.
MURAT: Ja, das liegt auch daran: Ich hatte Geld.
DIDI: Ja, das auch! [Lacht]
MURAT: Müssen wir nunmal zugeben.
Ich war schon…
SALLY: Der Körper!
MURAT: Ja, und der Körper. Genau.
DIDI: Ja, du hast so ein gemütliches Bäuchlein.
MURAT: Wenn ein Österreicher sagt: "Du hast einen gemütlichen Körper!",
will er damit sagen: "Du bist fett!"
Aber es ist richtig? Ist es nicht so?
DIDI: So, jetzt geht's ans Eingemachte.
Jetzt müssen wir die Pfannen richtig heiß werden lassen, gell?
Schau, ich habe dir da etwas vorbereitet.
Öl.
MURAT: Dankeschön.
DIDI: Na! Du hast Öl im Palatschinken.
MURAT: Ja natürlich!
DIDI: Dann machen wir halbe halbe.
Ja gut, dann…
MURAT: Wieso? Ich brauche das nicht. Glaub mir!
DIDI: Ich glaube, du brauchst das alles nicht.
MURAT: Ich mache nämlich ein One Pot Pfannkuchen,
d.h., alles in den Teig rein, dann umrühren.
Glaub mir, es wird funktionieren.
Du wirst dich wundern.
DIDI: Ja? [Murat bejaht]
Und Sally…
Kannst du mir einmal helfen, bitte?
Ich möchte auf beiden Seiten die gleiche Hitze.
Das macht die Sally. Ich glaube, die Technik macht die Sally.
Das, glaube ich, ist besser.
SALLY: Ihr habt nämlich beide den PerfectFry Sensor.
Ihr könnt hier einfach auf die Pfanne gehen und dann auf Stufe 4.
Da müsst ihr den Herd nicht mehr einstellen.
Der hält dann die Temperatur von den Pfannkuchen.
MURAT: Hat jemand gerade QVC bestellt?
SALLY: Nein, ich bin Bosch-Techniker.
DIDI: Kann ich noch ein bisschen heißer?
SALLY: Willst du heiß?
Stufe 5 ist…
DIDI: Das meiste?
SALLY: Stufe 5 ist Steak anbraten.
Stufe 4 ist Pfannkuchen.
DIDI: Dann nehme ich 4. [Sally stimmt zu]
MURAT: So, mein lieber österreichischer Freund.
Wenn dich der Murat jetzt mal schön in die Pfanne haut.
DIDI: Dann ist aber Schluss!
MURAT: Dann musst du daheim sagen:
Der Murat hat mich in die Pfanne gehauen.
DIDI: Greif auch mal rein. Wer länger drinnen halten kann. [Beide lachen]
Aha. Ja, das schaut aber gut aus.
MURAT: Ich finde es aber cool, wenn ich ab und zu mit Didi rede.
Der Didi ruft mich unter der Woche ab und zu mal an und lässt anklingen,
um mich kurz zu beleidigen. Dann legt er wieder auf. Hauptsache…
DIDI: Genau, einfach so schnell…
MURAT: Also ich wollte dir nur sagen, du hast - was weiß ich -
einen Dachschaden und dann legt er wieder auf.
DIDI: Am liebsten um 5 Uhr in der Früh.
Ja, das mag ich immer.
Dann ist aber die Sally immer dankbar,
weil er dann aufsteht,
macht eben Kakao, Frühstück für die Kinder und die Familie.
Das finde ich schon schön bei dir,
dass du das wirklich täglich machst.
MURAT: Und wenn das Video nachher zu Ende ist, sagt er:
Ich habe dich richtig schön in die Pfanne gehauen. [Didi lacht]
So. Didi, sind wir so weit?
DIDI: Ja, es geht los, oder?
Es hat zwar noch nichts gebimmelt.
MURAT: Ja, wir warten noch ganz kurz.
DIDI: Wir machen das ja mit Lagerfeuer in Österreich.
Vorher Holz hacken…
MURAT: Hast du es gehört? Deiner hat schon gepiept.
DIDI: Oder hast du ausgeschaltet? [Murat verneint]
Wehe du spielst da jetzt etwas herum!
MURAT: Nein, deiner hat schon gepiept.
DIDI: Okay. Deiner noch nicht.
MURAT: Er hat einen Vogel.
DIDI: Aber wir machen es jetzt schon so:
Jeder darf 2 oder 3 Palatschinken machen,
weil der erste meistens nicht so schön wird. [Murat stimmt zu]
MURAT: Ah, siehst du? Krass, oder?
DIDI: Jetzt geht's los. Okay, starten wir!
MURAT: Ich weiß, es ist ein bisschen anstrengend, uns zwei zuzuhören,
ohne ADHS bekommen,
aber es wird richtig cool.
Also fangen wir an, Didi.
DIDI: Dieses Rezept müsst ihr unbedingt nachkochen.
Gut. Leere mal alles rein!
MURAT: Mach du zuerst!
DIDI: Schau… schau, ich mache das jetzt so, ja?
Ich leere mal so rein.
Danach… Ah, ein bisschen mehr noch - zack, zack!
Schau her, jetzt schwenke ich die Pfanne schön.
Und schau, dass der Palatschinken…
MURAT: Willst du einen oder mehrere machen?
DIDI: Zwei mache ich.
MURAT: Ich mache nur einen.
Ja, weil ich es mag, wenn der Pfannkuchen so richtig schön dick ist.
DIDI: Schau, schau! Zack, zack, zack!
Unglaublich. Ich bin einfach wie der Hansi Hinterseer.
MURAT: Hansi Hinterseer?
DIDI: Weißt du, du bist mehr der Florian…
Wenn wir beide jetzt Österreicher wären,
wärst du Florian Silbereisen und ich wäre eben Hansi.
Ist gut!
MURAT: Ich meine, die Deutschen lieben Florian Silbereisen.
DIDI: Was du hier machst: Er macht Kaiserschmarrn.
MURAT: Ah!
DIDI: Das wird ein richtig guter…
Aber ich glaube, deiner dauert noch eine halbe Stunde oder so…
Ich schaue mir das jetzt mal an.
MURAT: Okay.
DIDI: Dann kann man das aufheben, hauchdünn, und dreht es wieder um.
MURAT: Was man aber auch sagen muss: Die Pfanne ist schon krass.
DIDI: Die ist wirklich gut.
MURAT: Die ist echt krass. Und zwar…
DIDI: Sallys Pfanne.
MURAT: Das ist Sallys Pfanne.
Wir dürfen aber keine Produktplatzierung machen,
weil wir es sonst kennzeichnen müssen.
DIDI: Aber wenn ein Produkt gut ist, dann ist es keine Platzierung.
Ja, das ist dann ehrlich.
MURAT: Ja okay.
DIDI: Und ehrliche Menschen gibt es viel zu wenig.
Darum bin ich heute bei dir.
Das ist mir wichtig.
MURAT: Was hast du gerade?!
Willst du mir gerade sagen, dass ich…
Schön, dass wir wenigstens einen ehrlichen Menschen
vor der Kamera haben.
Sonst wäre das nicht der Fall gewesen.
DIDI: Also mein Freund, haben wir Marillenmarmelade oder so?
MURAT: Genau.
Was er mit Marillenmarmelade meint, ist Aprikosenmarmelade,
er nennt sie aber Marillen.
Ich liebe es übrigens,
wenn ihr Österreicher immer Wörter anders sagt als wir
und ich dann verstehe, was ihr damit sagen möchtet.
In Österreich heißt übrigens auch Backrohr.
Ihr sagt Backrohr zum Backofen, gell?
DIDI: Ja, manchmal.
MURAT: Und das Coole bei beiden Österreichern ist auch…
DIDI: Das Schöne ist, man braucht ihn nur reden lassen
und der Tag vergeht.
MURAT: Was ich bei den Österreichern richtig cool finde, ist,
wenn ihr sagt "Tschau Baba".
DIDI: Tschau Baba?!
MURAT: Ja, sagt ihr doch, oder?
DIDI: Ja klar, ganz oft.
Wir sagen "Servus! Griaß di, mei Freund!"
MURAT: [Beide lachen]
Aber ihr sagt auch "Tschau Baba", gell?
DIDI: Nein. Tschau babatschi. Babtschi!
MURAT: Babatschi?
DIDI: Babtschi - In Wien oder so sagt man manchmal "Babatschi".
Wenn du mich jetzt nochmal ablenkst und mein Palatschinken verbrennt,
dann werde ich richtig böse.
Gut, ich lege ihn mir jetzt
- deiner braucht ja sowieso noch -
MURAT: Genau.
DIDI: Den ersten lege ich schon mal her.
Schön dünn, kann man durchschauen.
Was sehe ich denn da? Den Murat! Hallelujah!
MURAT: So, früher hat der Didi übrigens auch Kindersendungen moderiert,
wollte ich gerade ich sagen. [Didi stimmt zu]
Eins, Zwei oder Drei.
DIDI: Dann hab ich noch so kleine Gesichtchen reingemacht.
MURAT: Didi ist auch der Erfinder der Bärchenwurst.
DIDI: Was ist die Bärchenwurst?
MURAT: Kennst du sie nicht? [Didi verneint]
Das gibt's bei euch in Österreich nicht?
Wir in Deutschland haben dann anstatt Mozzarella Mortadella.
DIDI: Der kommt aber aus Italien, und nicht Österreich.
Das weiß der Murat nicht.
MURAT: Und den Kindern haben wir dann zum Essen ein Bärchen draus gemacht,
dass die Kinder sagen: "Och guck mal, schön, ein Bärchen!"
Dabei war es dann…
DIDI: Ah, ja!
MURAT: Kennst du die?
DIDI: Ja, ich hab ja auch selber zwei Söhne.
Denen hab ich das mal gekauft, glaube ich.
MURAT: Bärchenwurst? [Didi bejaht]
DIDI: Boah! Der wird jetzt ein perfekter Palatschinken.
Unglaublich!
Das ist wirklich österreichische Handwerkskochkunst.
MURAT: Wir sind heute ein bisschen langsam.
Wir warten, aber dann wird es genial. [Didi stimmt zu]
[Didi lacht] Lacht jetzt nicht!
Alle, die lachen, fliegen hier raus!
DIDI: Aber ganz ehrlich:
Wenn ich in meinem Restaurant Palatschinken so langsam  machen würde…
MURAT: Dann wärst du pleite!
DIDI: Dann wäre es vorbei!
So, ein bisschen noch.
Das Wichtigste ist, dass du der Sally ihre Pfanne nie zerkratzt,
dass du nur mit so einem Maxi…
Das ist wieder ein anderes Wort.
Wir sagen Maxi dazu.
Wie sagst du dazu?
MURAT: Das ist ein Silikonlöffel.
DIDI: Silikon Löffel - sehr vornehm!
MURAT: Was sagt ihr dazu?
DIDI: Maxi! Und mit dem Maxi fasst du rein.
Dadurch lässt sich eigentlich der Palatschinken perfekt lösen.
Dann brauchst du so richtige Männerhände wie ich
und mit denen kannst du dann den Palatschinken wenden.
Siehst du das?
MURAT: Darf ich das mit meinen… was ist das? Bärenhänden?
Waschbär vielleicht.
DIDI: Waschbärenhände.
MURAT: So, Didi, jetzt pass auf!
DIDI: Aber jeder Mensch ist ja sowieso Tier.
Du wärst so ein Waschbär.
Und ich bin so..
Kennst du diesen schönen Schneeleoparden in Sibirien?
MURAT: Ja. Du wärst ein Schneeleopard?
Ein angeschossener vielleicht.
DIDI: [Lacht] Ja, einer der etwas humpelt.
MURAT: So, jetzt pass auf!
DIDI: So, mein Freund.
Jetzt haust du alles um.
MURAT: Jetzt pass auf, was ich jetzt mache.
Und zwar ich warte, bis sich die Oberfläche kristallisiert.
Es ist ein krasser Trick von mir.
Und dann tu ich den Palatsch… nein, den Pfannkuchen…
Fast hättest du mich gehabt.
Den Pfannkuchen in der Pfanne wenden und mache einen Trick draus.
DIDI: Okay.
MURAT: Es ist wirklich…
Ich schmeiße es hoch, kommt dann runter
- wird hammermäßig funktionieren.
Das ist wie ein eigenständiges TikTok-Video.
DIDI: Da bist du ja mittlerweile auch schon sehr bekannt.
MURAT: Ja, ich bin bei TikTok unter "der Waschbär".
DIDI: Der Waschbär - das ist aber gut.
Also ich bin ja schon bei meinem 3. Pfannkuchen oder Palatschinken.
Und Murat, was machst du jetzt?
MURAT: Und zwar Folgendes:
Bei mir ist die Oberfläche noch nicht kristallisiert.
Deswegen werde ich ein chemisches Verfahren anwenden,
damit er auch richtig fest wird.
DIDI: Wie nimmt man dieses Verfahren? Mit Dampf garen.
MURAT: Mit Dampf garen, genau.
DIDI: Ah, d.h., deine Pfanne kann grillen, dämpfen…
MURAT: Ja, und dünsten
DIDI: und dünsten.
So, mein Freund.
Ich habe jetzt schon zum Anrichten für uns Teller vorbereitet.
Und du hast Marmelade.
MURAT: Ja, aber wir dürfen nachher der Sally nicht sagen,
was deins war, was meins war, gell?
DIDI: Dürfen wir nichts sagen. Nein!
Aber ich glaub, deine Frau kennt den Unterschied.
Wieso nimmst du den wieder weg?
MURAT: Das Problem ist: Ich glaube, meine Frau…
Weil du jetzt extra aus Österreich so weit bis hierher gefahren bist.
Dann will sie dich nicht enttäuschen.
Dann nimmt sie dich eher als mich.
Das weiß ich jetzt.
DIDI: Dass ich hier wohnen darf?
Dann sagt aber meine Frau wieder, das ist nicht gut.
Naja, mit dir kann man schon leben.
Du bist halt unser Waschbär.
Heiß? Hast du dich verbrannt?
MURAT: Pass auf! Jetzt kommt der Hammer. Pass auf!
Jetzt wirst du als österreichischer Koch sagen:
Krass, wie hat er das wieder gemacht?
DIDI: Du wirfst. Bitte sag es, weil dann gehe ich raus.
MURAT: Mache ich. Pass auf! Wirst du gleich sehen.
DIDI: Wie neu ist die Küche?
Relativ neu. [Murat stimmt zu]
Dann ist sie bald kaputt.
MURAT: 3 Jahre.
DIDI: So.
MURAT: Jetzt pass auf! Das ist ein geiler Trick.
Denn die Oberfläche vom Pfannkuchen ist jetzt
wirklich nicht hart geworden; sie ist noch flüssig.
Damit sie auch oben richtig kross wird,
dass ich sie wenden kann, mache ich den Deckel drauf.
DIDI: Das war aber gewollt?
MURAT: Das war gewollt. Natürlich, bei mir ist immer alles gewollt.
Immer. Das ist auch wichtig.
Jetzt pass auf, mein kleiner Freund!
DIDI: Jetzt mach!
Wenn du Hilfe brauchst, sagst du mir Bescheid.
Na bitte, Murat.
MURAT: Jetzt pass auf!
Der war…
DIDI: War gut!
MURAT: Das war schon sehr, sehr gut.
DIDI: Das war ein verschossener Elfmeter.
MURAT: [Lacht] Danke schön!
DIDI: Der war aber gut. Der war aber gut.
Du hast es probiert.
Jetzt! Du musst dich trauen.
Im Leben gehört es dazu, dass man sich auch mal Sachen traut.
Tun, nicht reden.
MURAT: Okay, los!
[Heroische Musik]
DIDI: Aber…
MURAT: Verdammt, das war die falsche Seite - ist wieder zurückgekommen.
Pass auf!
DIDI: Das jetzt nochmal. Geht schon!
[Applaus und Jubel]
Großes Kompliment.
Aber der ist perfekt.
MURAT: Der ist perfekt. Hast du schon mal… ?
DIDI: Der ist oben schon staubtrocken.
Siehst du? Wie eine Wüste.
MURAT: Ja, das ist auch Mississippi Mud Pie Pfannkuchen.
DIDI: Nein, Desrt!
MURAT: Genau, Desert!
DIDI: Desert Pancake.
Da haben wir wieder etwas Neues erfunden.
Vielleicht bekommt das den gleichen Hype wie Mirror Glaze.
MURAT: z.B.
DIDI: Hat Murat schon wieder erfunden.
Unglaublich, dieser Mensch!
Also von vielen wirst du ja auch verglichen mit dem,
der Tesla erfunden hat.
MURAT: Elon Musk.
DIDI: Ja, ich finde, ihr beide seid schon ziemlich…
MURAT: sehr ähnlich, genau.
DIDI: So, mein Freund,
ich nehme mir jetzt mal deine gute Kuvertüre,
sagst du da dazu, gell?
Streiche ein bisschen was rein, nie zu viel!
Gut, also meine Marmelade ist schon mal schön verstrichen.
Jetzt kommt mein Trick.
Schau, schau dir das an!
Das ist große Kunst - einrollen!
MURAT: Krass, er kann Pfannkuchen einrollen.
Ich zeige euch mal, wie der Murat das macht, und zwar…
Pass auf!
Seht ihr das? War das ein Move? War das ein geiler Move?
Das war ein Move, Murat.
Das war ein richtiger Move.
DIDI: Das war ein richtiger Move.
Und jetzt, mein Freund.
Magst du auch Marmelade oder… ?
MURAT: Ich mache was anderes als du.
Weißt du, was ich krass finde?
Ich weiß ganz genau, dass meine Frau kommen und sagen wird:
Ihr habt beide gewonnen.
Sie ist nämlich Grundschullehrerin
und bei meiner Frau gibt's keinen Gewinner und Verlierer.
Deswegen wird sie 100 %-ig kommen und sagen:
Ich finde beide voll süß und voll toll gemacht.
DIDI: Und in Wirklichkeit findet sie meine viel besser.
Das ist einfach schön.
Gut. Also ich würde sagen, ich mache ein Muster.
MURAT: Ich kenne mich leider in der Küche nicht aus.
Ist suche gerade nach Yammlou.
DIDI: Was ist ein Yammlou?
Murat, was ist ein Yammlou?
[Automatisierte Computerstimme]
COMPUTER: Nachdem der Rest dem lieben Didi nicht erklären wollte,
was ein Yammlou ist,
übernehme ich das jetzt mal.
Ein Yammlou ist eine bis jetzt unerforschte Ziegenart,
die in den Arganwäldern von Marokko ihr Unwesen treibt.
Sie wird in einer Kombination aus Mandelmus, Honig und Arganöl
zu einem Brotaufstrich verarbeitet.
MURAT: Ich habe hier ein Spar-Premium,
und zwar die Gartenhimbeere.
DIDI: Die hast du nämlich auch gepflückt.
Das finde ich sehr schön, dass du dir auch die Zeit nimmst,
dass du zu uns nach Österreich kommst und Himbeeren pflückst.
MURAT: Wahnsinn!
DIDI: Jetzt geht er…
So, aber bevor wir es der Sally geben…
Ich finde, das ist irgendwie auch diese Ehre, die wir zwei haben.
Du darfst meinen probieren, ich darf deinen probieren
und wir sagen ganz ehrlich, wie es uns geschmeckt hat.
MURAT: Alles klar. [Lacht]
DIDI: Weil ich bin ehrlich, weißt du?
Wir Österreicher sind ehrlich, wenn wir Skifahren den Gästen lernen,
wenn wir Tennis spielen den Gästen lernen.
MURAT: Wandern…
Wandern auch? [Didi bejaht].
Im Fußball?
DIDI: Fußball…
Da sind nur die Italiener nicht so ehrlich.
[Beide lachen] Das müssen wir jetzt mal ehrlich sagen!
MURAT: Er mag Italiener.
DIDI: Man nennt das Schwalbe. [Murat stimmt zu]
Okay, mein Freund.
Also das wäre jetzt mein Teller.
Ich glaube, das könnte man in einem Restaurant servieren…
Hä? Wann hast du das gemacht?
… al Murat, das wäre das Neue.
MURAT: Pass auf, wenn du jetzt einen coolen Move machst.
DIDI: Ja, jetzt machst du noch den Move.
Das ist deine Palette.
Schau, Murat, das ist deine.
MURAT: Wenn du denkst, du kannst mich hier foppen, dann hast du dich aber…
DIDI: Oh, du machst ein Klapp-Sandwich. [Murat stimmt zu]
Du machst eine Pizza.
MURAT: Pass auf!
DIDI: Er wird immer kreativer.
Da macht man mit dir Palatschinken und dann bekommt man eine Pizza.
MURAT: Pass auf!
DIDI: Schön warm noch, auch gut.
Meins wird schon wieder kalt, weil wir auf dich warten müssen.
Oh! Die arme Sally tut mir jetzt schon… Verdammt!
MURAT: Okay. [Didi lacht]
DIDI: Aber ich hab den Trick für dich.
Tu etwas Staubzucker drüber.
Dezent, ja! Du hast Gefühl.
Unglaublich! Von dir eine gute Rückenmassage zu bekommen
- das wäre mal etwas Feines.
MURAT: So, also los. Dann kann sie probieren.
DIDI: Aber…
MURAT: Didi, wir brauchen ihr ja nicht erzählen, wer was gemacht hat.
Meine Frau kent meine Handschrift.
DIDI: Wir tun es jetzt nur…
Wir holen sie rein, oder?
Und dann soll sie probieren.
Wir zwei gehen aus der Küche und dann soll sie kommen.
Sally!
SALLY: Ich mach das so aber nicht!
Ich will auch so einen Jurorentisch,
so wie bei Küchenschlacht und The Taste.
Die haben doch immer so einen Jurorentisch.
Haben die nicht auch Schilder?
MURAT: Dafür hat das Budget nicht gereicht.
SALLY: Oder ist das Let's Dance?
Let's Dance hat Schilder, oder? Okay.
Haben die bei The Taste auch Schilder?
DIDI: Da gibt's Schilder, ja.
SALLY: Haben die auch Schilder?
DIDI: Sterne gibt's auch noch zu verleihen und zu gewinnen.
SALLY: Welche Kategorien gibt's dann?
Dann bewerte ich die Kategorien.
DIDI: Naja, es gibt die Kategorie Freestyle…
SALLY: Freestyle, Aussehen,
Geschmack [Didi stimmt zu]
Technik, Handwerk oder so?
DIDI: Technik.
SALLY: Okay!
DIDI: Ich würde sagen, du beginnst mal, Sally.
Murat, wenn ich ab jetzt bei dir daheim einziehen darf.
Ich freue mich dann so!
SALLY: Wer hat was gemacht oder darf ich das nicht wissen?
DIDI: Nein, das darfst du nicht wissen. Das ist eine Blindverkostung.
Und da wir beide vom Typ her ziemlich ähnlich sind,
richten wir auch fast ähnlich an.
MURAT: Wir haben uns übrigens mit der Sally beim Blind Date kennengelernt.
DIDI: Du und Sally?
SALLY: [Lacht] Alles andere…
DIDI: Gab's damals schon diese Internet-Plattformen?
Ja? Du bist ja im Internet ganz fleißig. [Beide lachen]
SALLY: Also rein optisch hätte ich jetzt eigentlich gesagt,
das ist Didi, das ist Murat,
aber vielleicht wollt ihr mich ja auch auf die falsche Fährte locken.
und habt es vielleicht genau andersherum gemacht,
weil ich ja weiß, dass er Sternekoch und du…
MURAT: Was heißt das? Wie "ich"?
SALLY: Und du Sternchenkoch.
MURAT: Ich bin außerhalb der Konkurrenz.
DIDI: Es gibt keine Konkurrenz für dich.
SALLY: Ich bewerte den Geruch.
MURAT: Hä? Wir haben das Gleiche reingemacht.
DIDI: Naja, ich hab ein bisschen mehr…
MURAT: Ich glaube…
SALLY: Den Punkt fürs Aussehen…
- der Gerichte, nicht euch; der Gerichte! -
Aussehen, kriegt dieser Teller hier einen Punkt.
DIDI: Wir dürfen uns aber noch nicht freuen.
MURAT: [Jubelt]
DIDI: Sonst weiß man, wer die gemacht hat.
SALLY: Beim Geruchstest bekommt dieser Teller den Punkt,
weil es einfach irgendwie fruchtiger riecht.
MURAT: Das ist die Marmelade, die Gourmet Marmelade von…
DIDI: von dir gepflückt.
MURAT: … Interspar.
SALLY: Jetzt Geschmack.
Ich meine, die Technik kann ich vielleicht auch bewerten.
Ich meine, so sollte ja Crêpe oder Palatschinken aussehen:
Schön dünn, schön rollbar.
Das ist schon ein bisschen mehr Pfannkuchen, aber halt schon dick.
Aber manchmal steh ich auf dick.
Das ist nicht so.
Also bei manchen Dingen muss es so dicker sein.
bei Kaiserschmarrn zum Beispiel.
Aber Technik würde ich jetzt hier diesem Teller einen Punkt geben.
Jetzt Geschmack…
DIDI: Ich glaube, vielleicht denkt sich die Sally auch…
SALLY: Ist da Orange drin? [Didi bejaht]
Mmh!
Oh!
MURAT: Ist richtig fluffig, gell?
SALLY: Der ist richtig fluffig.
Vielleicht…
DIDI: Ja. Ich glaube auch…
SALLY: Ich meine, was war denn die Aufgabe?
War die Aufgabe "Palatschinken" oder war die Aufgabe "einfach lecker"?
DIDI: Einfach lecker, glaube ich. Das ist das, was im Leben zählt.
MURAT: Ja, und keine Gehirnzellen verlieren während des Kochens und Backens.
DIDI: Das hat mich schon Nerven mit dir gekostet.
Ich bin echt fertig.
SALLY: Eigentlich bin ich Team rote Marmelade, eigentlich,
aber hier muss ich sagen, mag ich doch die Orangenmarmelade lieber.
Und ich mag hier die Konsistenz lieber, weil es schön dünn ist
und die Marmelade zwischen jeder einzelnen Schicht drin ist.
DIDI: Aber fluffige ist auch gut.
SALLY: Nur leider ist der Teller nicht fluffig, sondern eher teigig,
schon ein Stein im Magen.
Also geht Punkt Geschmack auch hier hin.
Dann hat doch dieser Teller für mich gewonnen.
DIDI: Jaaa!
SALLY: Herzlichen Glückwunsch!
DIDI: Danke, Sally!
MURAT: Ich muss aber ehrlich sagen, dass wir in Deutschland…
Wir lieben es einfach ein bisschen mehr.
DIDI: Extremer.
Murat, darf ich bitte auch mal deinen probieren?
Gut?
SALLY: Geschmacklich schon gut, aber die Konsistenz…
DIDI: Das Schöne ist: Wenn man den Teller gegessen hat,
braucht man den ganzen Tag nichts mehr essen.
Das ist dein Lebensmotto.
Einmal kochen und den ganzen Tag…
SALLY: Leider ganz schwer.
MURAT: Ich finde, ein cooler Pastrami passt rein.
Ist ein bisschen Schinken, ein bisschen Ding;
ich glaube, der ist mehr für herzhafte Gerichte.
DIDI: Herrlich, vielleicht noch ein paar Oliven dazu.
Aber nicht schlecht, Murat.
Waren das deine ersten Palatschinken?
MURAT: Ich glaube schon, ja.
SALLY: Aber da ich dich sehr liebe.
ist es okay. Also ich würd es essen.
Ich würde es für dich essen.
DIDI: Und du darfst auch weiterhin bei der Sally bleiben.
SALLY: Ich muss wieder nach Österreich fahren, aber…
Aber nur wenn die Küche sauber ist.
DIDI: Genau. Aber ich glaube, wir gratulieren auch unseren Murat mal
mit einem schönen Applaus,
weil er unser Waschbär und unsere Nummer 1 ist!
MURAT: Kann ich jetzt mit Stempel auf die Hand haben, oder?
DIDI: Jetzt lass mich bitte mal was Gutes probieren.
MURAT: Du kannst dich in meinen Freundebuch eintragen.
DIDI: Darf ich? [Murat bejaht]
Die hab ich immer im Kindergarten und in der Volksschule verloren.
Du auch?
Die haben sie mir immer mitgegeben und ich hab sie immer verloren.
MURAT: Dann habe ich immer Ärger von deren Eltern gekriegt.
DIDI: Ich auch.
MURAT: Mein Gott.
SALLY: Ich lass die Zwei mal!
DIDI: Bis ich dann gesagt habe, ich will und brauche keine Freundebücher…
SALLY: Tschüss! Und aufräumen nicht vergessen!
MURAT: Ja genau.
DIDI: Du auch nicht, gell?
Wir wollen einfach… wir zwei reichen uns vollkommen.
MURAT: Wir wollen in Ruhe gelassen werden.
Also vielen, vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen.
Liebe Grüße an die österreichischen Zuschauer und an die….
DIDI: deutschen Zuschauer natürlich!
MURAT: Das ist natürlich österreichisch-deutsche Freundschaft.
DIDI: Ja, dieses Mal hat Österreich gewonnen,
aber das nächste Mal kann es ja wieder anders…
Da können wir "Schuschuk" machen, oder wie das heißt.
MURAT: Sucuk!
DIDI: Genau!
MURAT: Mir machen das nächste Mal Wiener Schnitzel.
DIDI: Auf ein Ehrenwort. Passt! Also seid wieder dabei!
Das nächste Mal gibts Wiener Schnitzel.
Wir lassen uns es jetzt schmecken.
Wir wünschen euch noch einen schönen Tag.
MURAT: Tschaubaba.
DIDI: Gutes Nächtle. Tschüssi.
[Musik]